warning the following video contains
spoilers is a freaking reaction video
what do you expect previously on
invasion of the giant stupid naked
people I mean a sack on Titan yeah
second much one piece fans I'll never
get bored of this opening okay so wait a
minute a 50 meter tall colossal Titan
appears out of nowhere raises hell
starts a shitstorm disappears into thin
air and not a single person around them
saw how it happened
simply jet so you've had five years to
figure out that the gate was obviously a
massive weak point congratulations on
four sites guys I think the technical
term for these kinds of moment is shits
be getting real oh my god they're
playing chess you know that means watch
out obvious badass coming through here
right Lelouch how long before this
geezer dies a horrible horrible death
damn what you doing looking again whoa
whoa whoa dude dude calm the [ __ ] down
while you have to go see a doctor you
look like you got the [ __ ] plague so
let me get this straight
the Titans only eat humans don't eat
animals but can live without eating
anything they can survive cannon ball
fire are physically superior to humans
in every way and regenerate their
[ __ ] heads after taking too much
damage
hacks I call hacks oh but they don't
have genitalia so they can't have sex
sucks to be them countless lives lost a
city under siege
Titans everywhere making hell on earth
and a response team in charge of
protecting all our lives ah teenagers
well we're screwed this looks so goddamn
cool some more of this please well [ __ ]
I better start the kill count
god damn did he just lose a leg my
little Titan can't be this cute double
kill triple kill
humiliation holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] wait is that Darwin Titan oh do you
want to move dude ironically the Darwin
Award goes to
don't you dare and this episode on a
[ __ ] flashback and our one legged
hero saves the day okay you can stop
with this epic speech already and just
hurry up and get out of that goddamn
mouth you've saved a friend dude
this seriously is not the time to be
monologuing aunt holy [ __ ] what what
what is this like I don't even how okay
how do I put this into words what the
[ __ ]
hey guys did okay I hope you enjoyed
that reaction to attack on titan episode
5 now I wasn't planning to do any
reaction videos for attack on Titan and
I might not do so much in the future but
you guys requested it and it was a big
episode so I wanted to do something if
you want my serious reactions attending
well I was seriously shocked when I
first saw it like many of you probably
were but now that I think about it I'm
kind of worried because how can they
possibly solve this without some kind of
a school or some kind of dicks machina
plot writing oh no I'm I'm scared
because this is obviously could be a big
turning point and you know it could
possibly go downhill in terms of writing
and I actually don't know how they can
solve this without some kind of shitty
ask for so I'm kind I'm kind of scared
but at the same time it was an amazing
episode but I just hope that it doesn't
go downhill from here
so to the rest of you manga readers
please don't spoil me I'm serious don't
put any spoilers in the comment section
I don't want to read them I'm gonna wait
and if you're new here and this is the
first time well I've already done a
first impression of attack on Titan
which you can see somewhere here and as
always I'm watching attacking types on
the crunchyroll and if you want a free
trial then go to WWE when she watched
the anime zone for free fortnight a
Premium Membership and you can also find
me on Facebook or Twitter in the
description below but as always I've
been gig up I'm going to be waiting
patiently for the next episode and I'll
see you all next time